on a fait quelques courses on a
réapprovisionné le la maison
globalement elle était contente de pas
trop me voir et pourquoi pourquoi le
volume horaire à un moment il faut pas
que voilà plus de quelques heures par
semaine elle se lasse un peu hélas
j'ai l'impression que moi on se voit
plus on s'aime ouais parce que forcément
et donc là ça va là vous êtes comment
tous les deux pas si mal Siri
tapothéose un peu virtuel mais apothéose
quand même d'accord
si vous voyez jamais
dedans si vous voyez jamais
vous d'abord et puis on se voit de temps
en temps quand on a envie de se voir et
c'est très bien une fois par an c'est
super
[Rires]
non mais j'ai changé les clés de la cave
j'ai fait beaucoup de bricolage ce
weekend je suis très contente
j'ai pas la clé je trouve que tu vois
hein tu veux pas changer les clés de la
CAF tu es pas chaud là-dessus quoi non
non parce que on a une partie de notre
vie qui est à la cave donc régulièrement
je chante
dans des dans des valises on a une case
ah c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que
j'ai fermé parfois la cave j'adore les
caves j'adore les caves et en fait pour
tout vous avouer j'adore la cave parce
que moi j'aime beaucoup vivre dans le
noir et elle a besoin de lumière donc
quand j'ai besoin d'un peu de noir je
vais recueillir à la fin de Mamie
tu es tranquillement avec ta meuf tu es
tranquillement avec ta meuf à un moment
tu dis j'ai un peu dans le noir
va dans le va dans la salle de bain tu
es à la lumière casse pas la tête j'aime
bien les caves pour tout vous dire ah
ouais
et que ta femme et que tu lui dis non
c'est pas vu depuis un moment quand même
bizarre
toute ma vie mais les catacombes je
connais par cœur à Paris parce que
j'avais une entrée secrète quand j'étais
jeune pour les catacombes et je faisais
des soirées bien sûr mais bien sûr
je vis dans le noir je m'épanouis dans
le noir voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]